the blast fall finals came to a close
over the weekend and even though it was
a relatively low-key event we got a
pretty important outcome there was a ton
of spicy moments the deciding map in the
grand finals was an absolute heater and
all in all it was super emotional but
most importantly a lingering question
might have finally been answered as
kadian been redeemed
before we get into it I wanted to remind
you all that we now got merch listen it
is only getting colder out there
especially here in Toronto so there's
nothing I would want more than to wrap
myself in a nice new warm hoodie we also
got a ton of other great merch that
would make perfect gifts during this
holiday season so follow the link in our
description box to our store website and
hey maybe pick up something for me
alright so even though the blast fall
finals wasn't the most hyped up
Tournament of all time there was
actually a lot riding on some of these
games you see the majority of this event
consisted of teams that didn't perform
well or at all in Rio so this was the
chance for a lot of teams and players to
redeem themselves with all that being
said it was hard to believe that this
event could end up being one of the most
intense and emotional Grand finals I've
ever seen
[Music]
but how the hell did we get to a crying
Canadian being hugged on stage by his
mom and how did heroic come back from a
heartbreaking defeat at the major and
pull it off against FaZe of all teams
well for that we need to go all the way
back to the beginning and get some
context let's start with G2 who were
probably the biggest question mark
heading into this tournament since they
were the ones that didn't make it to the
major and let's be honest they weren't
doing too well even before that but
coming into blast they had plenty of
time to rest reflect dye their hair so
fans were hoping that they would see a
new G2 and things would finally turn
around for them unfortunately that would
not be the case G2 barely made it to the
playoffs and when they did they were
soundly defeated by heroic getting sent
home early from yet another tournament
to make things worse even yakindar
commented on how unimpressed he was with
the team how are they going to come into
this after so long off
I honestly thought that they have the
advantage they had so much time uh to do
something to prepare new things and to
like change this the gameplay on all the
maps and but what I saw is that they
literally played the same boat on
vertigo and Mirage and uh
I don't know I think they could have at
least changed something at this point I
don't know what the answer is for G2 and
I honestly don't think anyone else does
either less than a year ago G2 was a
team cursed by second place finishes but
I'm fairly certain that nowadays they
would gladly accept a result like that
listen I will always be the first to say
that Esports should take a page from
traditional Sports in understanding that
results don't come instantly but it's
pretty bad when other teams
start commenting on your lack of success
hell I'm not even sure if G2 trusted
themselves anymore after the first map
Maniac mentioned that you had some some
work to do in the map too some critique
was uh probably also warranted on top of
Mirage how do you take that
the rest of the playoffs saw some pretty
interesting matchups between a bunch of
teams that were ready to make statements
and let me just say statements were
definitely made starting off nip
actually beat Navi which ended up being
a giant middle finger to all the people
who doubted them after their
disappointing 0-3 exit at the Rio major
and I'm not making assumptions on how I
think the team felt campus practically
spelled that out for us yeah all the
talents saying we should lose I mean
talents are used
people who want to be Pro players who
couldn't make it right so uh
who are they to say anything
that was spicy however nip weren't the
only ones being vocal on the other side
of things we saw a pretty massive
breakdown from Navi you see there has
been a lot of talk recently about who is
going to be the fifth man on Navi moving
forward since some die Young's
performances are now being called into
question and this made things awkward
since we were basically just all
watching some Die Young fight for his
career and after seeing simple tilts
round after round I'm not exactly
confident that things are going to
remain the same come next year but both
him and hopes actually so far
this event to look quite Sharp
it was a it was a good move right there
from Simply took a big risk swinging
that wide at a pit now with all that
spicy happening including na getting
sent home earlier than we'd like once
again the real story came in the grand
finals and I'm not referring to the Lord
himself Nicholas Bender playing in an
actual CS go show match on stage I'm of
course talking about heroic versus FaZe
and let me just say both teams clearly
had something to prove on one hand we
have heroic was there Deep Run at the
major just a product of upsets or could
this squad finally prove to everyone
that they are in fact topped here on the
other we have FaZe obviously they were
embarrassed at the Rio major but even
before that we saw the crown start to
slip a little this was supposed to be
their year so a win here would
definitely restore some Faith but once
things started it was clear both teams
came to play after each team won their
map picks they found themselves in an
absolute heater on Mirage heroic took a
convincing 11-4 lead in the first half
but FaZe did what they always do best
clawed their way back and forced over
time broke up above him sees his head
and smashes him against the wall oh the
tap from jabby and the yeah
take 10.
legal aggressive move being made middle
clearly there's that nade is immense but
twists taken down it's gonna give rain a
great chance
Norwegian Annihilation inside connector
heroic have been stopped shushed no will
at this time phase keep the game going
and frokey not yet around that corner
didn't see him until
and phase into the 1v2 oh
the Kerrigan keeps the dream alive it
has to go to overtime but for whatever
reason FaZe just couldn't handle the
reset in OT heroic was doing everything
right and it led to them winning the
tournament in front of their home crowd
and let me just say you could
immediately see how much this win meant
to them especially kadian it's down in
with the up and now Rob
rub
they made their dreams come true
to win inside the Royal Arena
a historic day
three for Danish Counter-Strike
the emotional man of Canadian somebody
who has hit rock bottom unlike so many
others they've gone through it all
Cadian was practically in tears from the
moment they won the match and to add to
all the emotions this happened because
they said kind of execute you know what
to do from a to to C
[Laughter]
ope
well it's fine but
mom
[Laughter]
if you're new to CS you might be
wondering why the hell is this guy
crying so much and why did his mom come
on stage to hug him mid-broadcast and
that's fair because this does not make
sense if you're lacking some much needed
context so Cadian is a guy who has been
through a lot as a player and most
people won't dispute that but in recent
years kadian and to an extent heroic
have become quite polarizing in the
community but why well a lot of this
stems back to the infamous coaching bug
heroic's former coach Hunden was
notoriously banned for exploding the bug
back in 2020 to help his team win
tournaments but in August of 2021 he
claimed that the players knew and even
helped him after those accusations the
players involved released an emotional
video explaining their side of the story
and esek found them not responsible
since they were being manipulated by
Hunden despite all that there's many
people who still dislike kadian and
think that he's a cheater on top of that
there's others who think that his nice
guy attitude is all an act to get people
on his side but at this tournament
things finally looked a little different
if you've been paying attention to CS
over the last year you may have noticed
something with the crowd they were
actually cheering for Heroic this is
notable because just last year they were
getting booed at the same tournament by
the same fans
now danish fans are notorious homers so
maybe they were just cheering for them
because they finally admitted to
themselves that astralis is cooked but
nonetheless I couldn't help but notice
it regardless ever since the cheating
bug incident and to an extent even
before that kadian has been fighting to
get a big win on land to prove that he's
not an onlineer and not a cheater and at
the blast fall finals he finally did it
hidian and heroic defeated one of the
greatest teams in the world and no one
can take that away from him listen you
don't have to like the guy but at this
point I think you have to respect his
determination
I want to see a poll in the comments how
we feeling about Canadian do he got that
dog in him oh my God excuse me why does
Kerrigan look exactly the same every
time he loses the tournament he's like
always just like has the same blank
expression and he's just like staring
it's the same expression I noticed at
every tournament